Nancy Pelosi holds a press conference
and she says I had Apple hey what
happened to my husband if he had a
Magnum 357 this wouldn't have happened I
am now in favor of the second amendment
that was my second thought the first
thought was well how injured was he
hopefully he's okay kind of thing and
then the brain surgery did he have a gun
did he didn't fire on this this home
Intruder we could have gone in San
Francisco bro yeah so like if he had had
a gun and the guy broke in with a hammer
to crack his skull he probably would
have fired on the guy put him down and
then ended the invasion in in that that
again is a radical idea that makes no
sense at all clearly what we have to do
here is Ban hammers hammers are the
problem there's too many of them anyone
could just get them without any
background checks anyone could just
transfer a hammer to another person
clearly right now the government has to
intervene go to Home Depot immediately
no shut down the Hammers no no no no no
one is actually saying bad hammers we
just want Common Sense Hammer control
okay yes